I did set out to like, you know, this has always been a serious language. The intention was always for it to be used in industry. And even if it's only been a little bit so far, it's really encouraging to see it like cross that milestone for real and be like, yeah, we did actually check that box. And knowing like how rare it is that a language that sets out to do that even actually makes it to that point. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 158 recorded on November 13th, 2023. My name is Connor. Today with my co-host Bryce, we continue part three of our four-part conversation with Richard Feldman, the creator of the Rock Programming Language, and we chat about what the status of the Rock Programming Language is, where it's being
我确实想过，你知道的，这一直是一门严肃的语言。它的初衷就是被应用于工业界。即使到目前为止它只被应用了一点点，但看到它真正跨过这个里程碑，并觉得“是的，我们确实勾选了那一项”，真的非常令人鼓舞。并且你也会知道，一门立志于此的语言甚至能够走到这一步是多么罕见。欢迎来到ADSP播客，第158集，录制于2023年11月13日。我的名字是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，继续我们与Rock编程语言的创造者理查德·费尔德曼（Richard Feldman）进行的四部分对话的第三部分，我们将聊聊Rock编程语言的现状、它在哪里被
used in production, and more. Speaking of which, what is the state of the art of Rock Programming right now? I know that from listening to your podcast that there are folks out there using it for personal projects and stuff. Because other it a, cause other languages like Carbon, I don't think has a compiler. It has an interpreter. Hilo, I think just released their compiler on gobble.org. And what's the other one that's being worked on? Oh yeah. CPP2. I think that has some amount of a transpiler. I don't know if they're calling it a compiler, but the other languages, I'm not sure if rock fits into that space, but they're the languages that we talk about on this podcast from time to time, you know, don't have, no one's going and building like, you know, applications in them
在生产环境中使用，以及更多内容。说到这里，目前Rock编程的最新技术水平是什么？我从听你的播客中得知，有些人正在用它做个人项目之类的东西。因为其他语言，比如碳语言（Carbon），我觉得它没有编译器。它有一个解释器。希洛（Hilo），我想刚刚在gobble.org上发布了他们的编译器。还有另一个正在开发的语言是什么？哦对，CPP2。我想它在某种程度上有一个转译器。我不知道他们是否称它为编译器，但对于其他语言，我不确定Rock是否适合那个领域，但它们是我们在这个播客中不时讨论的语言，你知道的，并没有人去用它们构建什么
right now. So what is rock? I think rock is a bit further ahead on you can, you can tell us. So I would say that, I mean, rock is at the point where people could be building applications with them. But I haven't seen anyone really set out and say, Hey, I'm going to do my project in Rock. I think part of the reason for that is I've been pretty vocal about discouraging people from doing that. Because just because I, I'm very aware of like, you know, how many bugs are in the compiler and like, you know, how much work we have to do before it's sort of like a stable experience. And I would hate to have someone start on a project before the language is ready, and they just get part of the way through and they just get blocked and it's like I'm sorry you know you got to wait until we finish this you know this part of the project having said that that is
应用程序。那么什么是Rock呢？我认为Rock在这一点上要稍微超前一点，你可以，你可以告诉我们。所以我想说的是，呃，Rock已经达到了人们可以用它来构建应用程序的程度。但我还没有看到任何人真正下定决心说：“嘿，我要用Rock来做我的项目。”我想部分原因是我一直直言不讳地劝阻人们这样做。因为我非常清楚，你知道的，编译器里有多少Bug，以及，你知道的，在我们把它变成一种稳定的体验之前，我们还有多少工作要做。我可不想让别人在语言还没准备好时就开始一个项目，然后做到半路就卡住了，这就好比“对不起，你知道的，你得等到我们完成项目的这部分才行”。话虽如此，这种情况正在
changing I think at this point it's a reasonable choice to build applications in rock and we're about to update the website to reflect this so depending on when this episode goes out that might be in the past but here in real time it's the plan is to ship that on next week i don't know if you how long you're this episode will either be coming out uh this friday which is the so no it's not coming out because the first episode was strange loop and then our right our hard left tangent into hawaii land so that'll be the 17th and then this one will either be in part one or part two so it'll be either November 24th or December 1st we'll we'll wait yeah the new website okay so past tense all right so as as you all know the new website uh is it looks much more like a normal uh programming
改变。我认为在这一点上，用Rock构建应用程序是一个合理的选择，我们正准备更新网站来反映这一点，所以根据这一集播客发布的时间来看，这可能已经成为过去了，但在这里的实时中，我们的计划是在下周发布它。我不知道，你这一集会播多久，呃，要么是在这个周五发布，所以——不，它不会发布，因为第一集是奇异循环（Strange Loop），然后是我们对夏威夷乐土（Hawaii Land）的硬左转切线，所以那将是17号，然后这一集要么在第一部分，要么在第二部分，所以它会是11月24日或者12月1日，我们会，我们会等待，对，新网站，好吧，所以是过去式，好吧。所以，正如大家所知，新网站，呃，它看起来更像一个正常的编程
language website whereas the previous website which I guess you can go to like archive.org to see what it looked like was very like bare bones no styling it was like hey this is a placeholder until we have a real website because we want the state of the website to reflect the state of the project um but yeah but but that's like i said that's changing um so yeah you mentioned this a little bit earlier but um the company i work for now vendor we've been working on introducing rock to the back end and that's been sort of my major project is um actually so we now have it where uh this is in production so we know it works like it's actually getting user traffic and whatnot uh and vendors a billion dollar company or at least that was their last valuation um that their last like fundraising round um but uh i i don't know
语言网站，而之前的网站——我想你可以去archive.org查看它以前的样子——非常基础，没有任何样式，就像是“嘿，这是一个占位符，直到我们有一个真正的网站，因为我们希望网站的状态能够反映项目的状态”，但是，是的，但就像我说的，这正在改变；所以，是的，你刚才稍微提到了这一点，但是，呃我现在工作的公司vendor，我们一直在致力于将Rock引入后端，这可以说是我的主要项目，呃，实际上，所以我们现在已经做到了，呃，这已经在生产环境中了，所以我们知道它行得通，就像它真的在接收用户流量等等，而且vendor是一家价值十亿美元的公司，或者至少在他们上一轮融资时的估值是这样的，但是，呃，我不知道
how much like what the actual traffic numbers are offhand, but, like, you know, in terms of number of users. The previous company I worked for, NoRedInk, had a lot of users, but not that high of a valuation. So, like, millions of users. But anyway, regardless, it's getting real user traffic. But it is very small. Like, what we've done so far is a little bit more than a proof of concept. It's, like, one step past that. So we haven't really, like, shipped a big feature more than a proof of concept. It's like one step past that. So we
实际的流量数字是多少，但是，你知道的，就用户数量而言。我以前工作的公司NoRedInk有很多用户，但估值没那么高。所以，大概有数百万用户。但无论如何，它确实获得了真实的用户流量。不过它非常小。比如，我们目前所做的比概念验证（proof of concept）稍微多一点。它就像是向前迈出了一步。所以我们实际上还没有在Rock中发布一个大型功能，比概念验证多一点。它就像是向前迈出了一步。所以我们
haven't really like shipped a big feature in Rock yet, for example. So one of the things that I did was based on my experiences introducing new programming languages, which granted is pretty limited, but I have done it at a couple of different companies. I have seen it go a lot better if you can have a really small level of granularity of introducing the new language ideally at the function level for example not at the service level not saying like okay we have to spit up a new service in this new language it's way better if you can just as we now have the ability to do it vendor take this node.js typescript backend and just import a rock module and just call a function from it and it just just works, which it does now. And we also open-sourced the way that we're doing that.
实际上还没有在Rock中发布一个大型功能，例如。所以，我所做的事情之一，是基于我引入新编程语言的经验——诚然这些经验非常有限，但我确实在几家不同的公司这样做过。我发现，如果你能以非常小的粒度引入新语言，理想情况下在函数级别，而不是在服务级别，而不是说“好吧，我们必须在这个新语言中启动一个新服务”，那么事情就会进展得顺利得多。如果你能像我们现在在vendor能够做的那样，拿到这个node.js的TypeScript后端，然后直接导入一个Rock模块并调用其中的一个函数，它就直接能用了——现在确实如此。而且我们还将实现这一点的方式进行了开源。
It's rock-esbuild, if you're curious about that. So you can use that in your project too if you're using esbuild, or even if you're not, like the bones are there to be able to use it in other systems as well. And also I had to do a separate thing for Jest, and there's an example in the repo of how to do that for the Jest test runner, if that's the test runner you're using. But basically, that is, as far as I know, the only example of Rock being used at production at a company.
如果你对此感兴趣，它叫做rock-esbuild。所以如果你在使用esbuild，你也可以在你的项目中使用它；或者即使你没用，基础架构也在那里，也可以在其他系统中使用它。此外，我还不得不为Jest做了一件单独的事情，仓库里有一个示例，展示了如果你使用的是Jest测试运行器，该如何为它做这件事。但基本上，据我所知，这是Rock在一家公司的生产环境中被使用的唯一示例。
If somebody else is using Rock in production, let me know. I'd be very curious to hear about it. But just thinking back to, like, I was kind of around in the early days of Elm, uh, like 2014, like, you know, almost 10 years ago now. Um, and I remember back when there was kind of similarly, there was one company using Elm for one thing in production, uh, which was circuit hub and they were using it for some little like widgets they had as, as part of their UI. And then, you know, another company started using it and people started doing side projects and this and that, it kind of grew from there. So I kind of think of Rocket being at a pretty similar stage where vendor is definitely the early adopters of, you know, using Rock in production.
如果还有其他人正在生产环境中使用Rock，请让我知道。我非常好奇想听到相关消息。但回想起来，我大概在Elm的早期阶段就接触过它了，呃，比如2014年，你知道的，现在已经快10年了。呃，我记得当时也有类似的情况，有一家公司在生产环境中的某项业务里使用Elm，呃，那就是Circuit Hub，他们把它用在作为其UI一部分的一些小型微件上。然后，你知道的，另一家公司开始使用它，人们开始做副业项目等等，它就从那里开始成长。所以我认为Rock处于一个非常类似的阶段，vendor绝对是率先在生产环境中使用Rock的早期采用者。
That sounds interesting, by the way, we're hiring. But basically, there aren't any other companies that I know of that have actually started, you know, building something substantial on it. And all the applications that I know of that people have done side projects and have all just been kind of like pretty small and like for fun. I would say the coolest one that I know of that somebody actually like, you know, shipped. Somebody built a mechanical clock that used servos to change sort of of like little fake lcds like you know lcd clocks where you have like the like the horizontal and vertical bars usually like green or amber or something um so he made one of those but the bars are actually like made out of wood or something and there's little servos that rotate them to change like what time it is
听起来很有趣，顺便说一句，我们在招聘。但基本上，据我所知，没有其他公司真正开始在它上面构建实质性的东西。据我所知，人们做副业项目的所有应用程序，都相当小，而且只是为了好玩。我想说我所知道的最酷的一个项目是有人真的将其发布了。有人用伺服电机（servos）制作了一个机械钟，用来改变类似于假液晶显示器（lcd）的东西——你知道像那种液晶时钟，通常有水平和垂直的条纹，通常是绿色或琥珀色之类的，呃——所以他制作了其中一个，但这些条纹实际上是用木头之类材料制成的，有小伺服电机旋转它们来改变当前的时间，
and he did the he programmed the servos in rock um on the like raspberry pi or something um so that's cool but that's obviously not the same thing as like it being a battle tested language which it very much is not yet still i mean it's it sounds like you're way way further ahead than um some of the other what do we call them successor i guess rock is not it's not aimed at being a c++ successor but oh definitely not no of the languages that we chat about they typically all are c++ you know successor initiative projects but a lot like as i mentioned before a lot of them um are still very early days like even carbon i think they have explicitly said like their
而且他在树莓派（raspberry pi）或类似设备上用Rock编写了伺服电机的程序，呃，所以这很酷，但显然这和它成为一个经过实战检验的语言不是一回事，它现在还远远算不上。不过，听起来你们比其他一些——我们叫它们什么来着？继承者——我的意思，Rock并不是旨在成为C++的继承者，但是哦，绝对不是，不。我们讨论的语言，它们通常都是C++的（你知道的）继承者倡议项目，但正如我之前提到的，很多语言，呃，仍然处于非常早期阶段，甚至像Carbon，我想他们已经明确表示他们的
roadmap is like half a decade or something before they're taking it very slow and experimenting and making sure that they're mapping things out in a certain way that they'll have really good backwards compatibility with C++, which is fair enough. You can attack designing language at whichever speed or design plan you want. But it sounds like rock is way further ahead because your company's actually,
路线图大约是半个世纪左右，或者是别的什么，他们走得非常慢，在进行实验，并确保以某种特定方式规划事物，以便与C++具有非常好的向后兼容性，这也很合理。你可以按你想要的任何速度或设计计划来攻克语言设计。但听起来Rock要先进得多，因为你们公司的确，
you know, you're, you're transitioning the backend. It sounds like to be entirely in rock or at least to a certain extent in rock. And that's like, you have to be at a at least a pretty good stage in order to be able to successfully do that. Right. Yeah. And I mean, we're expecting there's going to be bumps in the road and stuff like that. It's not like we're going to be like, all right,
你知道的，你们正在迁移后端。听起来是完全用Rock，或者至少在某种程度上用Rock。而且，为了能够成功做到这一点，你们必须达到至少相当不错的阶段。对。是的。我的意思是，我们预计路上会有一些坎坷之类的。我们并不是说“好吧，
everybody drop what you're doing and rewrite in rock it's more like you know the next milestone in my mind is let's ship a new substantial feature in rock because so far all we've done is just kind of been like okay let's let's try rewriting this little tiny chunk of logic that's you know somewhere in production into rock and see if it holds up under traffic and like you know doesn't do anything weird or surprising, which it hasn't. So great, you know, milestone passed. Another milestone was people other than me writing rock code at the company, because of course, at first, it was kind of all me just, you know, setting things up and whatnot. Also past that milestone, there've been two other people who have worked on the production code base, writing rock. But basically, like, you know,
大家放下手头的工作，用Rock重写”，更像是，在我看来，下一个里程碑是：让我们在Rock中发布一个新的实质性功能。因为到目前为止，我们所做的只是觉得“好吧，让我们试着把生产环境中某个地方的这小块微不足道的逻辑用Rock重写”，看看它在流量下是否经得起考验，并且（你知道的）不会做任何怪异或令人惊讶的事情——而它确实没有。所以太好了，（你知道的）通过了一个里程碑。另一个里程碑是公司里除了我之外其他人也在编写Rock代码，因为当然，一开始，基本上都是我一个人在设置各种东西等等。这也通过了那个里程碑，现在已经有另外两个人参与了生产代码库的编写，使用Rock。但基本上，就像，
shipping a substantial feature is obviously more work and also a greater level of risk of running into some showstopper that was unanticipated. A funny example was I was talking to one person who was working on the old rock thing at work and he was like, oh, what's the story around
发布一个实质性的功能显然需要更多的工作，同时也伴随着更高的风险，可能会遇到一些意料之外的阻碍。一个有趣的例子是，我跟公司里一个正在从事旧Rock项目的人聊天，他说：“哦，关于解析ISO 8601日期时间字符串有什么说法吗？”我说：“还没有，不过实际上我在Elm里写过那个库，所以我知道怎么做。”关于解析ISO 8601日期时间字符串有什么说法吗？我说：“还没有。但实际上我在Elm里写过那个库，所以我知道怎么做。”所以让我去，你知道的，快速拼凑一个出来。所以它们并不是特别复杂的解析格式。但归根结底，
parsing ISO 8601 date time strings? I was like, doesn't exist yet, but actually I wrote the library to that in Elm, so I know how to do that. what's the story around parsing ISO 8601 date time strings? I was like, doesn't exist yet. But actually, I wrote the library to that in Elm, so I know how to do that. So let me go like, you know, throw one together. So they're not particularly complicated format to parse. But at the end of the day,
总会有这样或那样的事情，当我们坐下来试图在Rock中解决一个问题时，就会觉得：“哦，这个现成的东西在哪里？”这就好比，嗯，现在现成的东西非常少，所以，你知道的，除此之外，还可能存在（你知道的）编译器Bug以及诸如此类需要应对的问题，呃，这其实就是使用尖端语言体验的一部分。你刚才说你们的下一个里程碑，或者你们的下一个里程碑之一是发布一些新功能。你们有一个功能清单，可以从中，
there's going to be stuff like that where we just, you know, sit down to try to solve a problem in Rock and it's like, oh, where's this off the shelf thing? It's like, well, the shelf is very small right small right now so you know uh plus on top of that there's potentially like you know compiler bugs and things like that to contend with um which you know it's just going to be part of the experience of using a bleeding edge language you said so your next is miles or one of your next milestones is going to be shipping some new feature. Do you have a list of features that you are going to be,
你知道的，试着挑选，还是说那是以后的事？我们确实有一份候选名单。呃，它们基本上与，
you know, trying to choose from, or is that, uh, down the road? We have a list of contenders. Um, and they basically have to do with,
呃，比如它们是否显得合适有关。很大程度上与一些权衡有关，比如：我们没有任何成熟的第三方生态系统，这会对我们造成多大伤害？换句话说，这其中有多少内容无论如何都必须从头手写？
um, like whether or not they seem suitable. A lot of it has to do with sort of trade-offs around how much is it going to hurt us that we don't have any kind of developed third-party ecosystem yet. Like in other words, how much of this is just going to be like handwritten from scratch regardless um and also other considerations are like how big of a project is this because again like you know the bigger the project the greater the downside potential if you do get blocked for whatever reason part way through it and then be like okay well we need to ship this so you know how how long
并且其他的考量还包括：这个项目有多大？因为同样地，你知道的，项目越大，如果你因为某种原因在半途被卡住，然后说“好吧，我们需要发布这个，所以还要花多久”时，下行风险的潜力就越大。如果速度很快或者有变通方法，那就没问题。如果没有，也许我们必须回去重写。而且你越是不得不回去重写，这事儿就越大。所以我们有一份候选名单，但我们还没有挑选出一个。这些讨论目前还在进行中。但对我来说绝对非常激动人心的是，我曾经在某个时刻思考过这个问题，我想：能够宣称除了创造它的人之外，还有其他人因为在工作中使用它而获得报酬的编程语言比例是多少？——好几个人，
is it going to take to remove the blocker if it's's fast or there's a workaround, that's fine. If not, maybe we have to go back and rewrite. And then the more you have to go back and rewrite, the bigger the deal that is. So we have a list of contenders, but we haven't picked one yet. Those discussions are sort of like in progress right now. But it is definitely very exciting to me that like, I mean, I was thinking about this at some point. I was like, what is the set of of what percentage of programming languages can ever say somebody other than the person who
而且在他们接受那份工作之前根本不认识对方。我觉得这是一个非常非常小的个位数百分比，可能还不到百分之一。哦，我以为你指的是总数，当时我想：那肯定得是两位数以上吧？但是按比例算，对，对，对，百分之一或者百分之一。哦，当然是的，有很多语言都做到过这一点，但是有更多、更多、更多的语言永远没有达到那个点，呃，特别是如果你把所有那些（你知道的）“我只是为了好玩在周末做了一个小语言”之类的项目都算进去的话。我发现了两种语言，分别叫“seriously”和“actually”。
created it got paid to use it at work like multiple people um who they never knew before they took that job like i think it's a very very small single digit percentage might be less than one percent oh i was i thought you were talking about total number and i was like oh it's got to be more than double digit but percentage percentage yeah yeah yeah one or one percent oh certainly yeah there's like lots of languages have done it but but way way way more languages never make it to that point um yeah especially if you're counting like all the you know i just made a little language for fun in a weekend you know type of projects i discovered two languages called seriously and actually.
当时我就想：什么？对。对。我的意思是，有这样的语言，并且（你知道的）这绝对没有任何问题。就像为了好玩而创造语言是很酷的一件事。但是，你知道的，我确实立志于，你知道的，这——这一直是一门严肃的语言。初衷一直是将其用于工业界。
I was like, what? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, there's like, and like, there's absolutely nothing wrong with that. Like it's, it's cool to make languages just for fun. But, but, you know, I did set out to like, you know, this, this has always been a serious language. The intention was always for it to be used in industry.
即使到目前为止它只被应用了一点点，初衷一直是将其用于工业界。即使到目前为止它只被应用了一点点，看到它真正跨过这个里程碑，并觉得“是的，我们确实勾选了那一项”，真的非常令人鼓舞。并且你也会知道，一门立志于此的语言甚至能够走到这一步是多么罕见。你，我发现这一点是因为我最喜欢的语言之一是一种叫做bqn的语言，它有点像下一代APL，目前它在GitHub上还没有被认可为一种语言，但它有一些第三方网站的标准，你必须跨越大约2000到200个仓库。他们非常接近这个标准了。你跨过那个门槛了吗？或者你也在朝着那个方向努力吗？是的，我们也问过同样的问题。因此，为了让.roc在GitHub上拥有语法高亮显示，我们必须拥有超过200个使用该语言的仓库，
And even if it's only been a little bit so far intention was always for it to be used in industry. And even if it's only been a little bit so far, it's really encouraging to see it like cross that milestone for real and be like, yeah, we did actually check that box. And knowing like how rare it is that a language that sets out to do that even actually makes it to that point. Do you, I discovered that
我们目前还没有达到。我其实不知道具体数量是多少，但我们在某个时候搜索了一下，感觉就是：“好吧，我们绝对没有马上要达到或者什么的。”呃，说实话，目前大多数仓库都只是人们在做“代码 advent of code”之类的东西，而且以后会有越来越多的库相关的东西，因为我们现在
because one of my favorite languages is a language called bqn which is like a next gen apl and it's not currently recognized on github as a language but it's like they have some criteria that some third-party site does and there you have to cross some like 2000 to 200 repos they're very close to that that. Have you passed that threshold or are you getting there as well? Yeah, we asked the same question. So in order to get.roc to have syntax highlighting on GitHub, we have to have more than 200 repositories
有一个正在工作但并非完全具备所有功能的，呃，类似于postgres适配器，呃，感谢奥古斯特（August），他写了那个，而且是用纯Rock写的。所以他在Rock中对Postgres的格式进行了二进制解码，这真的很棒。呃，他还写了一个GraphQL的。卢克·博斯韦尔（Luke Boswell）做过JSON，呃，并开始着手处理Unicode相关的东西。所以，有很多适合人们的机会。哦，呃，阿彻（Archer）开始搞正则表达式（regex）了，所以有很多类似（你知道的）软件包方面的东西可以涌现出来，然后还有，如果人们想开源他们的，呃，你知道的，语言项目——比如他们的应用程序——那么，你知道的，那也很酷，
that are using the language, which we do not yet. I don't actually have any idea what the count is, but we kind of like did a search at some point and it was like, okay, we're definitely not like right on the cusp or anything either um honestly like most of the repos right now are just like people doing advent of code and stuff uh and there will be more and more library stuff like we now
但，是的，我其实并不急于（你知道的）达到200个仓库，好让我们能拥有语法高亮。更重要的是人们正在享受这门语言，并发现它很有用。是的，我想这随着时间推移自然会发生的。我更好奇，只是因为——在Git上看到这一点确实很好，而且我认为这也算是一种认可的印记，说到（你知道的）成功或是多少人获得了报酬等等。我的意思是，这绝对也是一个里程碑，但它不是那种我想去刻意博取（game）的里程碑。你知道的，我不会去想：“哦，让大家每个人都创建五个使用Rock的仓库吧，
have a uh working but not completely fully featured um like postgres adapter that um shout out to august he wrote that uh and, and like pure rock. So he did like the binary decoding of like Postgres is format in rock, which is really awesome. Um, and he also did a graph QL one. Um, Luke Boswell has done like Jason and, uh, has started working on the, um, uh, Unicode stuff. Uh, so there's, there's a lot of like opportunities for people. Oh, um, Archer started on a rege regex um so there's a lot of like you know package stuff that can come up um and then also just you know if people want to open source their uh you know language projects uh like their applications then you know that's cool
这样我们就能尽快达到了。”我只会觉得：“是的，你知道的，该发生的时候自然会发生。”是的。我知道时间快到了，我不知道你是不是有硬性截止时间，但也许在最后的这几分钟里，我们已经讨论了一点关于语言特性的话题。我的意思是，我们提到了很多东西，我认为隐式地——如果你从C++转过来，生态系统方面的东西——我们真的没有一个标准的包管理器，我认为这是一个巨大的遗憾。但同时，你知道的，Rock在多大程度上支持元编程？因为我认为，在函数式语言中，关于编译期的事情有非常不同的说法，无论是根本不支持，还是通过列表、宏等支持。所以，是的，在那些我们还没有真正提到、可能会激起我们听众好奇心的东西中，请随意，你知道的，噼里啪啦地列举出来，无论是适用于Rock的语言、库还是生态系统。
too but yeah i i'm not really uh in a big rush to like you know get to 200 repos so we can get the syntax highlighting to be it's more important that people are enjoying the language and like finding it useful yeah i think that'll that'll just happen with time i was more curious uh just because i mean it is nice when you're on git and i think it's also kind of like a stamp of approval talking about you know the you know success or uh how many people get paid etc um i. I mean, it's definitely also a milestone, but it's not one that I'd want to sort of game. You know, I wouldn't want to be like, oh, let's everybody go make five repos,
好的，所以，有几件事情。呃，所以，Rock是一种纯函数式语言。这意味着没有突变（mutation）。没有副作用。我想既然这是一个对C++熟悉的受众群体，我可以大致讲讲它的内存表示是什么样的，或者我应该说内存表示将会是什么样的，因为我们还没有转换为这个，
you know, that use like Rock so we could get there as soon as possible. I'm just like, yeah, you know, it'll happen when it happens. Yeah. I know that we're getting close to time and I'm not sure if you have a hard stop, but maybe in the last few minutes here, we've talked kind of a little bit of the language features. I mean, we've mentioned a bunch of things, which I think implicit like ecosystem stuff if you know coming from c++ we don't really have a
但这将是它的最终形态，而且会无限期保持下去，所以我就直接用这种方式来谈论它了。基本上，输入输出（I/O）的工作方式本质上是这样的：假设我想从一个文件中读取一些东西，然后我想对它进行一些处理，并且我想把一些东西写回另一个文件。在Rock中，它的工作方式是——我们称之为“任务（task）”，这基本上是一个结构体（struct），它包含某种——实际上我想，好吧，它实际上是一个带标签的联合体（tag union）。所以假设它是一个联合体，在C语言的术语中，你有一个判别式（discriminant），它说明：“这是我想要执行的I/O操作。”所以它可以是文件读取或文件写入。然后它内部还包含传递给该系统调用或无论什么I/O操作所需的所有
standard package package manager and i think that's a a huge shame but like also like you know to what extent does rock support metaprogramming because that i think that is like across functional languages uh there are very different stories for, you know, compile time stuff, whether it's a, you know, they don't support it at all or they support it through, you know, lists, macros, et cetera, et cetera. So, yeah, like of the stuff that we haven't really mentioned that might pique our listeners' curiosity, feel free to, you know, rattle through things, language or library or ecosystem that apply to Rock. Yeah, so, I mean, a couple of things. Um, so, uh, rock is a pure functional language. So that means there is no mutation. There's no side effects. Uh, I guess since this is, I guess an audience that's familiar with C++, I can kind of talk about what the representation is, or I should say the representation is going to be, cause we are, we have not converted over to this yet,
信息。所以在读取的情况下，那可能是，这将会是——我们假设我们没有做类似于打开和读取的操作。我们假设我们只是提供文件路径。但当然，如果你愿意的话，你可以有一个单独的（你知道的）打开并获取文件描述符的操作。这个，嗯，这就涉及到平台和应用程序了，我想我接下来得谈谈这个。所以你有所需的操作，并且你拥有执行该操作所需的所有信息。然后你拥有的最后一件事，本质上是一个回调函数，它说：“一旦操作完成，我希望你调用这个函数。”该函数将运行并返回
but this is what it's going to be and what it's going to be indefinitely so I'll just talk about it in those terms basically so the way that IO works is essentially that let's say I want to do a I want to read something from a file and then I'm going to do some stuff with it and I want to write something back to another file so the way that that works in rock is what you have is we call it a task and this is basically going to be a struct that has some sort of actually i guess well it's really going to be a tag union so let's say it's a union um in c terms and you have a discriminant that says like here's the io operation that i want to do so it could be a file read or file write then it's got also inside of it, all the
给你另一个这样的联合体东西，它说：“这是我接下来想要执行的I/O操作。”所以本质上，现在我们有了一个语法糖，使得这看起来更像，我猜更像是命令式风格，也就是说：“好吧，首先执行这个文件读取，我拿回了这个东西，现在它在作用域内了，我可以，我可以对它做任何我想做的事。”有点像Haskell的do记号（do notation），看起来很相似。然后一旦我做完了我想要做的事情，接下来我就会调用这个文件写入。然后，你知道的，也许在那之后我再做一些事情。但本质上发生的事情是，这个数据结构是（你知道的）允许我们保持纯函数式的关键。任何时候你在做I/O，你其实并不是立刻运行I/O。
information necessary to be passed to that syscall or whatever the IO operation is. So in the case of read, that would be maybe, this would be, let's assume that we're not doing like open and read. Let's assume that we're just like giving the file path. But of course you could have a separate, you know, open and get the file descriptor if you wanted to. That's, well, that gets into platforms and applications, which I guess I'll have to talk about next. But so you have the operation that you want, and you have all the information necessary to perform that operation. And then the last thing that you have is essentially a callback that says, like, once the operation is done, I want you to call this function. And that function is going to run and give you
相反，你是在构建这样一系列东西：“这是我想要的I/O操作，然后这是一个同样是纯函数的、将返回另一个这种东西的回调函数。”一旦你构建好了，你的程序本质上就描述了这些东西的一个巨大链条。归根结底，本质上有一个运行时解释器会遍历并逐步执行所有这些东西。现在，这其中很酷的地方在于：第一，你获得了纯函数的所有优良特性。所以如果你调用这些返回任务的函数无数次，它们仍然只返回相同的东西。它们不会运行I/O操作无数次，
back another one of these union things that says, like, here's the next IO thing that I want to do. And so essentially, now we have syntax trigger that makes this look a lot more like, a lot more imperative, I suppose, in the sense of like, you know, okay, first do this file read, I get this thing back, now that's in scope, I can, I can do whatever I want with that, kind of like Haskell's do notation looks, looks similar to that. And then once I've done the stuff that I wanted to do, then I'm going to call this file write. And then, you know, maybe I do some more stuff after that. But essentially what's happening is that that data structure is, you know, is what allows us to be purely functional. Like anytime you're doing IO, you're not actually running the IO right away.
这对于缓存、可重放性以及所有这些各种事情都非常棒。但这也意味着，如果我想做异步操作，比如，你已经为之做好了完美的准备，因为你只需调用那个东西，运行I/O操作，然后直到你正在做的任何异步事情完成之前，你都不会调用回调函数。所以你可以随心所欲地交错执行这些操作。这种结构能够描述：我想先运行这个，然后再运行那个，或者我想并行运行这两个。我用现在时来描述，就好像我们已经实现了那部分一样，实际上我们还没有，但
Rather, you're building up this sort of series of, here's the IO operation that I want, and then here is a callback function that is also pure that's going to return another one of these things. And then once you've built up, your program sort of describes a big chain of these things. At the end of the day, there's essentially a runtime interpreter that goes through and steps through all these things. Now, what's cool about that is that, A, you get all the nice properties of pure functions. So if you call these functions that return tasks a bajillion times, they still just return the same thing. They don't run the I.O. operation a bajillion times,
它有能力描述：我希望你同时运行这个东西以及另外这个东西，并且我只希望你在它们两个都完成后，以它们实际完成的顺序去运行（你知道的）它们各自的回调函数。所以这样做有很多非常棒的特性，即使你并非刻意要成为一门纯函数式编程语言。另一个好处是：在许多具备这种异步功能的语言中，你会有分裂的生态系统，即你既有同步版本的I/O操作，也有异步版本。如果你把它们混搭使用，你通常会遇到不好的体验。在Rock中，
which is really nice for caching and replayability and all these various things. But also it means that if I want to do asynchronous, for example, you're perfectly set up for that because you just call the thing, you run the IO operation, and then you don't call the callback until whatever asynchronous thing you were doing is done. And so you can interleave these however you want. The structure is capable of describing like, I want to run this one and then that one, or I want to run these two in parallel. I say it present tense like we've implemented that part yet, which we haven't, but
我的意思是，作为一门纯函数式语言的约束所带来的奇怪好处之一，就是你根本不可能拥有同步版本。它甚至在语言中都无法被描述。所以一切都是异步的，这意味着你不会遇到分裂。每个人在任何时候都在一直使用异步的一切。这也是在语言中进行I/O的唯一方式。我想我在谈论平台和应用程序之前应该先停一下。不过我想这让你对（你知道的）这门语言大概是关于什么的有了个概念。所以我们确实有——尾递归消除（tail recursion elimination），以及模cons（modulo cons），对于那些知道这意味着什么的人来说。基本上，这意味如果你想让编译后的输出
it is capable of describing, like, I want you to run this thing and then also this other thing concurrently, and then I only want you to run, you know, both of their callbacks after they both finished in whatever order they happen to finish in. So there's a lot of really nice properties to doing that, even if you're not trying to be a pure functional programming language. Another advantage to this is, so in a lot of languages where you have an async capability like that, you have this split ecosystem where you have the synchronous version of the IO operation, then you also have the async version. And if you mix and match those, you tend to have a bad time. In Rock,
本质上变成一个循环，你只需编写一个尾递归函数，它就会被编译成一个循环。这意味着如果你编写一个递归函数，你实际上可以在Rock中实现一个无限循环，而且我们确实——像Rust一样——会检测一些基本的情况，比如如果每次调用都导致递归——其实我想我忘了我们是否完成了那个功能，那可能实际上还没有实现。我知道Rust有这个功能，我们要么已经有了，要么计划拥有。有一些你可以检测到的基本事情，比如“你知道的，我们无法解决停机问题，但你至少可以检测到一些显而易见的情况，比如‘嘿，这里没有基本情况，所以它显然永远不会终止’”。但无论如何，呃，所以使用这门语言感觉非常面向表达式（expression oriented），因为这基本上是你唯一能做的事情。
I mean, one of the sort of weird benefits of having the constraint of being a pure functional language is that you cannot possibly have the synchronous version. It's not even describable in the language. So everything is async, which means you don't have the split. Everybody's always using async everything all the time. And that's the only way to do IO in the language. I guess I should pause there before talking about platforms and applications. But I guess that gives you a sense of like, what the language is sort of about. So we do have like, tail recursion elimination, and also modulo cons, for those who know what that means. And basically, that means that if you want to get the compiled output
我们确实有几个语句，比如，`debug`就像是现在仅仅将（你知道的）某些东西写入标准输出，纯粹是为了调试目的，这是一个语句。然后我们有的另一个是`expect`，它有点像断言（assertion），但，呃，它就像Rust中的`debug assert`一样，基本上，它就像一个断言，但，呃，它就像Rust中的`debug assert`一样，基本上，它就像一个断言，只不过它不会使程序中断，如果它失败了，它只会把失败信息告诉你，仅仅出于（你知道的）你自己的信息目的，然后在优化构建中它就会被抛弃。所以这算是一种帮助自己进行测试的方法。哦，是的，如果在测试期间`expect`失败了，那么测试就会失败。所以这是一种在你的程序中
to be essentially a loop you just write a tail recursive function and it will compile to a loop which means you can actually have an infinite loop in rock if you write a recursive function and we actually do like rust we do detect a couple of basic cases of like if every call results in recursion i think actually i forget if we finish that that might not actually be implemented yet i know rust has this and we either do already or plan to have there's some basic things you can detect where it's like you know we can't solve the halting problem but you can at least detect some obvious like hey there's no there's no base case here so like it's clearly never going to terminate but at any rate um so using the language feels very expression oriented because that's kind of all you can do um we do
点缀一些你期望为真的小东西的方法——有点像在你的代码中编码假设，即使你觉得“但还没到那种如果到了这里我真的希望发生运行时崩溃的地步，我只是想知道它，但我并不想让它停止程序”。所以，是的，在我进入平台和应用程序之前，让我先停在这里，这是Rock中的大创意，我想也是它最独特的地方，它的语言特性集。而且，我不知道，
actually have a couple of statements like uh debug is like just right now just like write you know write something out to like the standard out just for debugging purposes that's a statement and then the other one we have is expect which is uh kind of like an assertion but um it's like debug assert in rust where basically it's it's like an assertion but um it's like debug assert in rust where basically it's it's like an assertion except that it doesn't halt the program it's just like if if it fails it'll tell you about the failure just for your own like informational purposes and then in an optimized build it just gets thrown away so this is kind of a way to help yourself out with testing oh yeah and also if it expect fails during a test then the test fails so this is a way to sort
让我们看看你怎么想，或者你有没有什么问题。我的唯一问题——我们看看布莱斯有没有——这种类似于任务链（task chaining）的I/O叫什么名字？这是Rock的人和你自己想出来的一个新奇事物吗？还是说这是一个从学术论文中借来的、带有一些深奥名字的想法？或者也许这是一个很流行的东西，而你刚刚在描述它，只是我没听说过？那个学术上的深奥名字叫做“延拓单子（continuation monad）”。
of sprinkle throughout your program little things that you expect to be true like sort of encoding assumptions in your uh in your code even if you're like but not so much that i actually want you know a runtime crash if we get here i i just want to know about it but i don't want it to like stop the program so yeah let me stop there before I get into platforms and applications, which is sort of like the big idea in Rock, I guess. And the thing that's most unique about it, it's language feature set. And I don't know,
这不是我想出来的。威廉·布兰登（William Brandon）——向威廉致敬。他告诉了我们这个。我其实并没有意识到这是你可以在具有Rock这种类型系统的语言中做的事情。但事实证明你可以，并且它有一堆非常棒的特性。我们只是刚刚触及了我们想用它做的事情的表面。我们计划了很多东西，如果我们在明年能把这些东西实现的话，我会非常兴奋。呃，但我不知道我们是否会实现，因为，这是一份相当长的一系列非常酷的事情，呃，我们想用这个来实现。但是，呃，我的意思是，它带来的结果，让我
let's see what you think or if you have any questions. I mean, my one question, and we'll see if Bryce has any, is there a name for that like task chaining IO? Like, did you, is that like a novel thing that a novel thing that the rock people and you came up with? Or was that like an idea borrowed from an academic paper that has some esoteric name? Or maybe it's a popular thing and you were just describing it that I haven't heard of. The academic esoteric name is the continuation monad.
最激动的是，从用户的角度来看，它感觉真的很简单。它感觉就像在使用promise、future之类的东西，或者像async/await一样，你只是觉得：“好吧，我有了这个我想要await的东西”，然后，“好的，然后我继续我的生活”。这里没有分裂，没有“哦，这个东西是异步的，另一个东西是同步的”这种区别。它只是：如果你在做I/O，它总是异步的。然后所有随之而来的美好特性，实际上大部分要么在幕后发挥作用，要么它们启用了一个特性，比如：“哦，太棒了，我有了这个我可以选择用于测试的新东西，或者是这个那个”，而这些我在其他语言中是无法使用的。那么这和CPS（延拓传递风格，Continuation Passing Style）是一回事吗？它是其中的一种形式。
I did not come up with it. William Brandon, shout out to William. He told us about this. I didn't actually realize that that was something you could do in a language that has the type system that Rock has. But it turns out you can, and it has a bunch of really nice properties. We're only kind of scratching the surface of what we want to do with it. There's a whole bunch of stuff planned that I would be very excited if in the next year we got those things implemented. Um, but I don't know if we will, cause it's, it's, it's a substantial list of like a really cool things, um, that we want to do with this. But, uh, I mean the, the, the upshot of it that I,
我的意思是，所以延拓传递的部分将会在那个数据结构内部。我的意思是，存在一个延拓（continuation），对吧？我用了“回调”这个词，但基本上就是这个意思。就像，（你知道的）你运行这个I/O操作。然后在那之后，就像：“这是我接下来想要做的事情。”这就是延拓，对吧？就像，这就是我们在做完（你知道的）无论什么I/O操作之后要做的事情。所以你可以把它想象成“嗯，我们挂起了
I most excited about it is that from a user perspective, it feels really simple. It feels like using like promises or like futures or something like that like or like async await like you're just like okay i have this thing i want to await it um and then all right then i keep going with my life uh there's no split between like oh this thing is async and this other thing is synchronous it's just like if you're doing io it's always asynchronous um and then all of the nice properties that come with it are really mostly either behind the scenes or they enable a feature where it's like oh cool i have this new thing that i can choose to use for testing or this or that um that i don't have access to in other languages so is this the same thing as CPS, continuation passing style? It's a form of it.
执行”，或者你可以把它想象成“嗯，实际上我们拥有的是一个延拓，它类似于：程序的其余部分来自这里。在完成相关的I/O操作之前，我们是不会调用那个延拓的。”我的意思是，这很有趣，因为我从来没有实现过延拓单子。但是，（你知道的）我读过关于它的东西。而且，我的意思是，布莱斯可以纠正我如果我错了，发送者和接收者（senders and receivers）不就是延拓单子吗？是的。所以那就像是一个新的异步算法。我不知道你管它叫什么框架，
I mean, so the continuation passing part would be inside that data structure. I mean, there is a continuation, right? I use the term callback, but that's basically the idea. It's like, you know, you run this IO operation. Then afterwards, it's like, here's the thing that I want to do next. That's the continuation, right? It's like, that's what we're going to do after we've done, you know, whatever the, the IO operation is. So you can think of that as like, well, we've suspended
布莱斯，我们一直——它已经被C++ 26接受了吗？还是没有？它已经通过了设计批准。我甚至不知道那——我不知道那是委员会黑话里的什么意思，但是，呃，让我们——让我们别担心了，我想我们不需要——是的，它正在按计划进行，但无论如何，关于具体细节以及未来某个新近的C++版本中，他们也实现或批准了一个语言特性/框架，本质上——我不认为在提议它的论文中任何地方有——但是等等，但是，呃，我认为C++的协程（coroutines）比Rock中的async要相似得多，我的意思是——而且在某种程度上
execution, or you can think of it as like, well, really what we have is we have a continuation that's like, here's, here's where the rest of the program comes from. And we're not going to call that continuation until after we've finished the IO operation in question. I mean, this is interesting because I've never implemented a continuation monad. But, you know, I've read stuff about it. And, I mean, Bryce can correct me if I'm wrong, but isn't senders and receivers just the continuation monad? Yeah. So that's like a new asynchronous algorithm. I don't know what do you call it a framework
在我们所说的协程中的awaitable是什么？awaitable本质上也可以是一个sender，但我认为这更类似于经典的async/await模式，我们在
bryce that we're has been proposed sure has it has it been accepted for c++ 26 or not yet it's been design approved i don't even i don't know what that i don't i don't know what that is committee speak for but uh let's let's not worry about i don't think we need to not yes it's on track but all right anyways about the specifics and potentially a new newer C++ near you and C++ near you in the future they've also implemented a or approved a language feature slash framework which is essentially I don't think actually anywhere in the paper that is proposed it but hang on but but i i think that c++ car routines are much more similar to the async and rock than uh i mean and there is some degree of
C++中也有。我认为它最相似的，是当今语言所采用的那种流行的async/await方式。对吧。据我理解，在C++中，一旦我们拥有了它，我们就能够在sender和receiver（也就是延拓单子）之上重新实现协程。在……之上重新实现协程？就像——我以为协程基本上只是延拓的一种特化或实现呢。
in what we call what's an awaitable in a coroutine awaitable essentially can be a sender to but I think that this is much more similar to the like the classic async await pattern which we also have in
在我们所说的协程中的可等待对象（awaitable）是什么，可等待对象本质上也可以是一个sender，但我认为这非常类似于我们在中也有的经典async await模式
C++ I think what it most closely resembles is sort of the popular async await way that languages do that today. Right. Which, to my understanding, in C++ we would be able to re-implement coroutines on top of senders and receivers, aka the continuation monad, once we have it. Re-implement coroutines on top like i thought coroutines is basically just like a specialization of or like an implementation of the continuation
C++，我认为它最相似的是目前各种语言中都很流行的async await方式。对吧。据我理解，在C++中，一旦我们拥有了sender和receiver（也就是continuation monad），我们就能够在它们之上重新实现协程。在顶部重新实现协程，就像我认为协程基本上只是延续的一种特化或实现一样
monad uh to do your async await stuff like continuation monad is like the most general pattern but like you can you see it everywhere right like there's a bunch of different i don't know if you call them specializations or applications it is definitely so so um senders allows you to express asynchrony that is that is linear chained and not strictly continuation passing style and it allows you to prep to express continuation passing style. And it allows you to express continuation passing style asynchrony. So you understand the distinction between those two there, Connor? I think so. But I feel like this is kind of like now I've treaded into academic waters that, you know.
单子，呃，用来做你的异步等待之类的东西，比如延续单子就像是最通用的模式，但你可以随处看到它，对吧？这里有一堆不同的——我不知道你该叫它们特化还是应用——它确实是这样的。所以，嗯，senders（发送者）允许你表达异步性，这种异步性是线性链式的，而不严格是延续传递风格，它允许你预先表达延续传递风格。它允许你表达延续传递风格的异步性。康纳，你理解这两者之间的区别吗？我想是的。但我觉得这有点像是现在我涉足了学术领域，你知道的。
No, it's actually fairly important and relevant to our platform. And it's a question of when are you going to know what the task is that you're going to enqueue. In a C++ coroutines world, where you've got a function that co-awaits. So I got three statements, each one co-awaits on a separate call to something. You know, after that first co-wait, the coroutine yields back.
不，这实际上相当重要，并且与我们的平台密切相关。这是一个关于你什么时候才能知道你要入队的任务是什么的问题。在一个C++协程的世界里，你有一个会进行co-await的函数。我有三个语句，每个语句都在对某个东西的单独调用上进行co-await。你知道，在第一个co-await之后，协程会把控制权交还回去。
And then you've got this function that you can call to resume the coroutine. And you have no way to look ahead and to know that, oh, you know, the next co-wait is going to co-wait on this expression. And then the next co-wait is going to co-wait on this expression. And then the next co-wait is going to co-wait on this other thing. Whereas in the sender's framework, you would express that as you build a pipe where you'd say like, then first thing I'm going to call, then second thing I'm going to call, then third thing I'm going to call. And then, you know, at the time of that task graph creation, you know and can see all three of those calls. And so you know exactly what's going to happen. Now in the C++ world, the compiler under the hood, it obviously has to know these things.
然后你就有了一个可以调用来恢复协程的函数。你没有办法向前看并知道，哦，你知道，下一个co-await将对这个表达式进行co-await。然后下一个co-await将对这个表达式进行co-await。然后下一个co-await将对另一个东西进行co-await。而在sender的框架中，你会这样表达：你构建一个管道，你会说，然后我要调用的第一件事，然后我要调用的第二件事，然后我要调用的第三件事。然后，你知道，在创建任务图的时候，你知道并能看到所有这三个调用。所以你确切地知道将要发生什么。现在在C++世界中，底层的编译器显然必须知道这些事情。
But the interface that C++ Curve Routine exposes to you, the user, and to you, the implementer of a scheduler or an execution context, all you get from a Curve Routine is just, hey, here's a thing that you call that will resume the thing. You don't get any other information about the task graph, which is very annoying for some execution contexts.
但是C++协程暴露给作为用户的你，以及作为调度器或执行上下文实现者的你的接口，你从协程中得到的仅仅是：嘿，这里有个东西你调用它就能恢复那个东西。你没有关于任务图的任何其他信息，这对某些执行上下文来说非常烦人。
Yeah, if you're trying to schedule stuff efficiently. All right, how does that map back? Did you track all of that, Richard? Was that all? Well, having personally used zero of those c++ features i didn't track great i mean in all fairness one of them doesn't exist yet and the other one has zero library support for it so there's only a handful all right well i don't feel too bad well so so i guess another another way to think about it is um
是的，如果你想高效地调度东西的话。好吧，这如何对应回去？理查德，你都听懂了吗？就这些吗？嗯，由于我个人使用那些C++特性的次数为零，我没怎么听懂。我的意思是，平心而论，其中一个特性还不存在，另一个特性没有任何库支持，所以只有少数人……好吧，那我感觉没那么糟糕了。好吧，所以我想另一种思考方式是，嗯
in the traditional continuation passing the like style like if i want to chain like three pieces of work like piece of work a is going to run to completion and then it's going to launch piece of work b that i'll run to completion and that's going to launch piece of work C. Yeah, totally. So the challenge with that continuation passing style approach, especially in this day and age, is that you might be running on an execution environment where you either cannot or it would be slow to enqueue the next piece of work. So like, for example, a GPU. On NVIDIA GPUs, we can do what's called nested parallelism or dynamic parallelism,
在传统的延续传递风格中，比如如果我想把三项工作串联起来，比如工作A运行完成，然后它将启动工作B运行完成，然后工作B将启动工作C。是的，完全正确。所以这种延续传递风格方法所面临的挑战，尤其是在当今时代，是你可能在这样一个执行环境中运行：你不能或者很难将下一项工作入队。比如，GPU。在NVIDIA GPU上，我们可以做所谓的嵌套并行或动态并行，
where you can have one kernel launch another kernel and launch another kernel, which has been supported on NVIDIA GPUs, but has been slow for a long time. We've recently released a new version of it, which is a little bit faster. But there are also some accelerators where to the place that can launch the work, especially if the continuation is wrapping a bunch of asynchronous tasks where we don't have to rely upon continuation, pass, and style where the control flow or the the what's the word I'm looking for like execution control does not have to be done in place execution control can be done a priori or can be prescribed or can be like left up entirely to whatever backend you choose to target. And this problem, I think, is to me the one major downside of async-await
你可以让一个内核启动另一个内核再启动另一个内核，这在NVIDIA GPU上一直受到支持，但很长一段时间以来速度都很慢。我们最近发布了它的一个新版本，它稍微快一些。但也有一些加速器，对于能够启动工作的地方，特别是当延续包装了一堆异步任务时，我们不必依赖于延续传递风格，在这种风格中，控制权或者——我找的词是什么来着？——执行控制不必当场完成，执行控制可以先验地完成，或者可以被指定，或者可以完全留给你选择定位的任何后端。我认为这个问题对我来说是async-await的一个主要缺点
in almost all the languages that I've seen it in, where it relies almost entirely on the continuation-passing-style model, which makes it a bad fit for execution environments that do not support or do not efficiently support running the next piece of work directly from that execution environment. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoy it and have a great day.
在我见过的几乎所有语言中，它几乎完全依赖于延续传递风格模型，这使得它不适合那些不支持或不能高效支持直接从该执行环境运行下一项工作的执行环境。请务必查看你的播客应用中或访问 ADSP the podcast.com 获取今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及可以留下评论、想法和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
高质量，低产量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。